pick up the phone at six o'clock goes oh
gotcha I got you and I I said Charlie he
goes I don't like hey dude
um and let's just split up with my
girlfriend at the time and I thought oh
well you know what I'm going to beat
around the bush I'm just going to
continue straight because you know break
the ice Tom do you remember the floods
Oxford because yeah the flag just
remember the floods yeah if you swim
with that boy because his foot stuck in
a great and the river kept rising and
they kept rising and he kept rising and
eventually they try to get him out but
he drowned yeah well that wouldn't have
happened to me right because you wanna
know why when yeah yeah sure it was
because I just said cut it off now son
is sometimes yeah you've got a cup a
little piece of yourself off yeah no
matter how much it hurts in order to
grow in order to move on